hey how are you um oh this movie oh my
goodness so incredible
um congratulations on the film first of
all um you know that opening birth scene
is almost 30 minutes long
it's done in one take vanessa i want to
know what was that moment like for you
when the director yelled cut and the
scene was over
yeah it was i mean it was a such a weird
experience because i guess
you know i hadn't given birth before but
in half an hour i kind of felt like i
had it was so weird
and also especially because there's like
a real baby in the in the scene with you
too
it's like so it's so tiny and um
honestly at the end of the take i i i
remember the first couple of times i
really did just sob for five minutes and
i had we had such a kind wonderful
director who knew
uh you know who he was holding space for
all of us i guess and he i remember the
one take he just came he just hugged me
for like
five minutes solid and he said to me
just remember this feeling remember this
feeling
because that's what the kind of feeling
i have to get into for the rest of the
film so
that happened but then also we had this
great kind of tool of like playing
really loud upbeat music and dancing
around the flat while the props being
reset we started again
so that helped because it just kind of
got rid of that um yeah
of the of how difficult it was at the
end of that having having lost the baby
yeah and how did you even begin to
prepare for for a scene like that
well i first started watching a ton of
documentaries
um and any kind of birth scene in films
i could find and
even with the documentaries i just it
was almost like a little bit sanitized
you know they would show you like
tiny moments and i to the point where i
because i haven't done it before
yeah um and i was so i felt really
privileged to learn about it because so
many people have or have watched it
um so i i realized that
in a way if we could try and make a
birth scene that
was true to the actual whole whole
birthing experience of even the time
between contractions and how
and the pain of it and like the amazing
parts of it and all the sort of things
in one of human experience
really that we've all gone through or
been come out
somehow um so i
yeah that was um anyway to answer your
question i
ended up being really lucky to work on a
labour board for a while
to to shadow the midwives in
obstetrician and then there was one
woman who
unbelievably allowed me to watch her
give birth and without her i never
could have done it in any way because i
wouldn't have been able to understand
any any parts of it really so it was her
wow uh ellen i loved your character in
this you know your character just wants
what's best for her daughter but it
doesn't always
come across in the best way sometimes uh
what was your approach to taking on this
role
oh um you know i
i kind of followed her trail
from being born into the holocaust to
living in a beautiful home where
she's into staging for everybody that
you know she the chair is just a chair
until you put a cushion on it
and then it's improved you know
it's more beautiful that that's who she
is
you don't just accept the the difficulty
and the plainness and the
problems of life you stage them
you make them better you present them
and you
you live up to the promise of something
instead of just being stuck
and that's the way it felt to me that my
daughter was just
not releasing it the energy it was just
she was it was all bottled up inside of
her
and i i felt she would feel better
if she would just give voice to it
to to speak it out and
not um not be
you know tight with it and i think in a
way i was right
i loved that
so that was my approach i loved it well
congratulations on the film it's
definitely one that you don't forget
very easily at all
so congratulations great job thank you
thank you
thanks